all right we have come to the final unit
here in health class sexual education
now this is mature subject matter and I
expect you all to handle it with
maturity like the young adults you are
becoming I'm scared Teddy wonder if he
shows us a diagram of a vaginer and I
get a boner hey you're getting a boner
before this class ends buddy the sooner
you wrap your head around that the
better sexual intercourse is a physical
expression of love and affection that is
perfectly natural and often deadly
sexually transmitted diseases include
gonorrhea HIV herpes chlamidia HPV
hepatitis A through C JFK Blown Away
what else do I have to say We Didn't
Start the Fire Ted knock it off see this
is exactly what I'm talking about to
avoid sexually transmitted disease it is
important to practice safe sex now who
can tell me what the safest sex of all
is no
one masturbation hey if you're going to
assign homework Johnny already did it
this morning shut the [__] up dude he's
doing extra credit be quiet stop it you
keep that up your headed for detention
Mister now why is it important to
practice safe sex well it all begins
with Biology oh here we go let's start
with the female reproductive
system oh no holy [__] that's fast even
for
you well glad that's over huh I know
that was like sex ed for babies what I
mean you're really going to talk about
masturbation and leave out edent
seriously he didn't even talk about how
massage in the prostate increases orgasm
intensity did you see how when I brought
up rimon he flipped to the
glossery wait you you two have had sex
no I'm felching my own jizz th was 16
when with ho few weeks ago with each
other we didn't want to be the last ones
in school to lose our virginity oh yeah
no right of course how how lame would
that be right wow I didn't even know you
two guys were dating Andrew I thought
you were gay I don't know might be I
just know I'm not a [__] loser you're
so confident I love it let's go to the
computer room we can do it on the Oregon
Trail holy [__] Teddy do you know what
this means I'm the last virgin in school
what about Ben Caris no he slept with
his math teacher that's why she got
fired I thought she got fired for giving
him angel dust yeah Teddy I think that
was the trade oh oh wow oh yeah well
then that's a mess anyway dude this is
serious I need to hurry up and have sex
with somebody before people find out and
I'm humiliated you're right we got to
find a buyer fresh penis get your fresh
penis here Jesus Christ this penis used
to belong to a little old lady who only
[__] it on Sundays still has that new
penis smell you shut up all right I'm
just trying to
help my words are lazy my thoughts are
hazy but this is one thing I'm sure for
all everybody needs a best friend I'm
happy I'm
[Music]
Yours